pouvait sani vous trouvez pas
franchement y'a que ni
et après il ya les garçons
chéri en parlant de castaldi tiens ici à
castanet sais combien d'années de métier
presque 30 ans presque 30 ans 30 ans
d'échec
[Applaudissements]
il a eu beaucoup de succès mais là il ya
eu un échec et une échec c'est vrai les
scieries lorsqu'on a tourné le pilote de
l'émission phare août on a brièvement
parlé de y'a que la vérité qui compte
avec benjamin castaldi on avait un
différend sur le fait que ça fonctionne
ou pas jusqu'à parier quelque chose ou
regarder c'était dans le pilote regardez
une fois de plus castaldi spécialiste
bien sûr médias de l'audiovisuel la
boussole qu'annick le sud exact si
castaldi te dis que ça va pas marcher tu
peux dormir tranquille et attendre les
audiences sereinement
regardez
moi je n'y crois pas je voulais dire
ouais enfin paris maintenant ah oui
taiwan chirac cartable 10 h 28 on parie
quoi c'est qu'ils allaient à paris des
mains non pas paris d'amis étudiants
soutien gorge pendant une semaine
et tu as en string 6 à mal à l'aise
partout
si on demande à l'origine m'afficher les
scores du hac l'aveyron
merci à la régie 1,1 c'est très beau
c'est 1,4 pour cent de parts de marché
plus d'un million téléspectateurs un
carton amenez-moi des soutiens gorge
[Applaudissements]
fois des
jeux sonia je serai avec mon bras
guillaume face à des gros bonnets déjà
merci non non non tu vois si
mixité c'est vrai qu'ils seront rouges
c'est pas bien ça revient à l'ex
animateur
soutien je vais passer l'émission a
perdu oui j'ai des cornes j'ai perdu au
fin quand même un peu à peu délité
[Applaudissements]
pour moi c'est cadeau soit
par la daytona
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je me sens très bien c'est qu'il ya un
truc et je me sens très jeune et pas
cher je te jure que c'est vrai non c'est
pas nous c'est un peu sympa nul un peu
sereine dans ces trucs de femmes mais
c'est surtout que tu as des gros lolos
sais pas